et
[Musique]
au coeur de beaune à deux pas des
célèbres hospices
voilà un cinq étoiles aussi côté que le
vignoble local
on peut vraiment parler de luxe à la
française
c'est votre première fois en bourgogne
bienvenue en tout cas heureusement se
promener dans les superbes cour de
l'hôtel le set ne coûtera rien aux
amateurs d'histoire donc là vous avez
arrivés dans la cour saint félix donc
une courte classé monument historique et
date du 16e siècle de 15 170,6 ce jour
là nous avons suivi ce couple de clients
suisses s'étaient déjà pour découvrir le
trésor de l'hôtel embouteillée là sous
nos pieds
alors bienvenue madame monsieur au
caveau saint félix mais aussi assister
une expérience inédite dans ce cas vous
dédié aux grands crus les étiquettes
comme les prix donnent le tournis alors
chaque verre ici est une fête
donc là on est sur quelque chose d'assez
inhabituel étant donné qu'on est sur un
vin qui se situe sur la sous région de
côte de nuits et la côte de nuits comme
vous le savez sûrement donc est un très
grand terroir à pinot noir ont produit
de très très grands vins rouges et très
peu de vin blanc de grands vins de
bourgogne que l'on déguste ici entre
deux bouchées de chocolat lait chocolat
avec le vin blanc j'ai loupé pas le
souvenir c'est vrai qu'on associé avec
des notes justement qu'on peut retrouver
sur ces vins donc sur les notes de
fruits blancs les fruits à chair blanche
ou alors les côtés citronnée de par les
agrumes sur le chocolat base de
bergamote également et ça fonctionne
aussi très bien avec les mains rouges
l'initiative est osé mais parfaitement
maîtrisée par le sommelier
c'est vrai qu'on a un caractère assez
fougue dans 1 2 par cette acidité le
côté très explosive du fruit et
tempérées justement par ces chocolats
seydoux ami avec cnc fruits justement
assez exubérant donc c'est intéressant
un immense étonnement parce que j'étais
pas fanatique du tout de l'association
entre les vins et les chocolats surtout
avec le chocolat noir et là je dois
avouer que on m'a complètement bluffé
comme on dit l'atelier baptisé terroir
chocolatées s'adresse à une clientèle
gourmande est majoritairement étrangère
plus de 70 nationalités se croisent dans
l'hôtel de monsieur bernard crois que
les français sont effectivement des
gourmands en terme de chocolat mais on
est quand même pas les seuls de ce qui
est intéressant pour nous c'est de
proposer à nos clients autre chose que
ce qu'ils connaissent déjà
c'est de les faire sortir un petit peu
de ce pourquoi ils sont venus
évidemment on va mettre un point
d'honneur à ce que la bourgogne qui
viennent rechercher
il la trouve et puis qu'on la partage
tels que nous on aime mais c'est bien
aussi d'arriver à les surprendre un
petit peuple dans le restaurant étoilé
qui se trouve tout à côté le chef
confirme la relation particulière
qu'entretient cette clientèle
internationale avec le chocolat au
niveau des japonais ils sont très très
très friands des chocolats et très
amateur ceux qui le sont un petit peu
moins sont les chinois après nous avons
les clients américains qui quand ils
viennent crocs du chocolat mange mais
laisse toujours quasiment les trois
quarts pour ne pas
tout manger parce qu'ils sont dans une
quête permanente de saveur les
chocolatiers travaille également les
grands crus de cacao
et pour ne pas faire de jaloux nous
verrons demain comment le vin jurassien
peut lui aussi enchanté le chocolat